it may not have been half life 3 but
valve did have a bunch of big news items
to drop today at GDC they had three big
announcements in fact but don't get any
ideas from that one the first big thing
multi announcement of steam link a
device that will enable game streaming
to televisions from a separate PC or
steam machine so long as you're on the
same network symlink will support 1080p
gaming at 60 Hertz and features an hdmi
port and Internet port and three USB
ports again don't get any ideas from
that sibling will be available come
November for 50 bucks if you're in need
of an input device the steam controller
will also be available for fifty dollars
valve also talked about a new system
that will work with their virtual
reality headset live call the lifehouse
it's a room scale tracking system set to
help boost resolution and tracking speed
for a lower hardware costs that one will
ship in April the developers at no cost
while consumers can pick it up in
November finally valve have announced
the source 2 engine a successor to the
source engine responsible for powering
dota 2 Celt a strike and half-life two
alone other title the new engine will be
free to content developers and
compatible with Vulcan the graphics
application programming interface that
Valve tees early last month let me know
which of Valve's announcements you cared
about most and why down in that comment
section will be giving you up dude on
all the news coming out of GDC 2015 so
keep it tuned against low
you